hello and welcome to this video playing
am sorry marina zara marlena so new
Sicilian especially come again no this
time probably the time honor no this one
a lots of trans positions here maybe we
get a specially called after all nope
this line okay clock I know t5 Bishop d3
is one of the lines Oh counseling first
hmm that's lit uncommon that this is all
I know isn't it a bit difficult for him
now to play d5 of a play Bishop g5 let's
see him normally black wants to play a
quickie d5 and play for his good
development it looks difficult now at
least him it would would be a sponsor
Kareem d5 would sacrifice a pawn I mean
my development is not that great so it
might be possible I quigley six actually
would have been a move as well right
Queen d6 was interesting just asking him
about how is ever going to move the deep
on ha I could have done that pen for me
I could have done that 05 now so 95 he
goes g5
what happens here I mean queen d6
stellar it's still an interesting move I
takes e4 I be sure to 89 txt six that's
probably good for Black Knight e5 there
is a yeah g5 is the play g5 looks
extremely dangerous
I cannot go 26 that's a that's a real
shame it's a move I would have liked to
play it feels like is wriggling out of
this a little bit i was thinking f for
now f form it looks very dangerous from
black f takes five there is a huge
threat and the calorie intake as the
night is hanging probably just back the
threat Bishop of 695 is pretty
substantial
and maybe now it's got Quincy five huh
again I'm going right into a double
check hmm anyway no we must push a moose
tonight so if i take it i'm opening up
the f found that should be the right
idea 95 c 2 is hanging see to a sane it
doesn't feel like very relevant that's
it hangs but it might be
no that game should have been over
already I did not finish this off and I
certainly could I mean I'm very sure i
could you know I played it correctly
maybe it's playing at Bishop you six or
something trying to simplify why is that
possible show me or is he just secondly
exchange your own so 97 1 anything else
okay
I still have active pieces I mean I
don't think you can just play with the
exchange down takes here okay and then
the room then then with this ok I can
take on f7 but this son might activate
on night b3 is potentially annoying move
maybe just back him taking his active
piece down the actor pieces to my tongue
maybe this is correct down to one minute
mm-hmm time morning so reason not to
take I don't think so
ok
I wonder if I should just take finite
fields on over there and I should prefer
I should first and foremost to make
moves just make moves 30 seconds 25
should be enough time check check check
check check check check check check I'm
a little bit quicker check check check
no time bloody time yeah life is forfeit
its fun time ok ok well played sir so
yeah let's see what we get from the 26
is already stronger here right yeah
normally they go d 5 in this position to
play with the better development and moo
cow yeah I don't know I spent lots of
time in the opening allow you to try to
totally refute it which yeah didn't I
mean that that is close to it if not a
complete complete refutation it was it
was slow yeah you get the exchange yeah
it should be enough
with any particular situation has spent
too much time check maybe I shouldn't
give that change when I can't locate it
attracts the win there's nothing nothing
else to say about it chatra CM check
taxes already held a tricky in this
eight seconds and so v6 was winning on
their own became the date sense check
check check Brooke a forward shot better
here right here yeah again I just needed
a couple of more seconds yeah I spent a
bit too much time in the opening to try
to refute this the setup yes it I came
close but it wasn't like he got
checkmated quickly or anything maybe
this was indeed better forcing him to
play g5 and in this situation here yeah
it's sometimes it difficult in the in
the open Sicilians this is not my home
ground and that makes me spend more time
than probably am regular Sicilian wipe
whiteside also say and play a would not
be should be three years seems to be
better covering this but champ probably
with this with a little bit more
precision I can I can finish the game
off in like 25 moves like here yeah you
see what the engine is giving this is
probably one one moment down here f5 is
interesting I didn't think about this
move i know i just wanted to open up the
bishop here but at five is also
extremely strong yeah this is this is
not allowing an ending probably he
didn't lose materially I mean this
surface somewhat them somewhat
hopelessly plays
mm yeah this is venom that doesn't
really allow any any hope for a whole
time win so anything probably this is a
mating attack oh okay yeah thanks for
watching